they're just living for the most part
they're just doing things they're not
supposed to be doing and by doing that
they're expanding freedom hi I'm Ted
baliker with Reason TV and today I'll be
speaking with Thaddeus Russell Russell
is a historian an author of the new book
the renegade history of the United
States tell me why did you write this
book I wrote this book because I came of
age trained by historians of the new
left Columbia University I received my
PhD and I was one of them I wanted to do
history from the bottom up and that's
what they promised that we're doing this
what they call the new social history
and you know over the years I found that
the heroes that they that they replaced
the old white men with actually had same
basically the same values that the the
great old white men the inventors the
generals the presidents had which are
essentially middle-class bourgeois 19th
century Victorian values around hard
work the Puritan work ethic and sexual
repression and the nuclear family
fortunately in the last 10 to 15 years
historians who came of age after the New
Left have begun looking at people like
prostitutes and criminals and drunkards
and slackers and and in doing that you
know it opened up a whole new way of
looking at American history and that's
this tension between the degenerate
immoral outcasts and those who are the
keepers of community and morality so in
a nutshell what what would be the main
takeaways in your book that you hope to
convey to people people who existed and
operated purely for their own pleasures
and interests expanded freedoms for all
of us and they broke open American
culture in ways that most of us not all
of us value in fact cherish today what's
generally wrong about the conservative
take on American history what's wrong
with the conservative meaning
classically conservative historiography
I mean that's that is sort of what
dominated until the 1960s which just has
a very narrow perspective you know it
was only that it was at what we call the
top-down history and it's I never
claimed that it's wrong I just claim
that it's narrow and it misses a whole
lot of the story and so by looking
simply at political leaders or Thomas
Edison or the generals you know you miss
a lot and you missed basically 99% of
the American population so what's what's
wrong with the
traditionally liberal take on history
they were invested basically in the
project of long-term project of the left
of making the working class or the lower
class into heroes and so what they ended
up doing was sort of pushing them into
these bourgeois middle-class boxes and
their heroes themselves people like
Martin Luther King and the great
suffrage leaders were that as well they
wanted to reform their own
constituencies they wanted to make women
and blacks and labor labor union members
into good hard-working family member
Americans you know in the in the service
of basically managing the country and so
the New Left became ferret was very much
engaged in that project and didn't ever
question unfortunately those values
which ironically come from a very
conservative class of the 19th century
Victorian moralists and you call it the
way you described your book a history of
America from the gutter up that that
kind of bottom-up worldview is is very
libertarian in and of itself who are
some of these gutter up
I begin with a look at the culture of
lower-class saloons during the War of
Independence and they were first of all
everywhere and they were on the streets
in all the cities the cities were full
of these lower-class saloons and in them
you found in to a much greater extent
per capita wives than they are today far
more per capita now than now and in them
you would find particularly the
lower-class saloons you would find a
great deal of interracial integration
many reports of whites and blacks in
those saloons drinking together dancing
together playing music together and the
music in fact that created in those
saloons became the basis for much of
American popular music Irish in
particular and ex-slave music was really
became the first sort of urban party
music and that really was the basis for
jazz and ragtime and rock and roll
you found women in those saloons with
men this is before the Victorian
crackdown on women participating in the
drinking culture and you just found a
general sort of anti-authoritarian Pro
Liberty culture in those saloons the
Boston Massacre was precipitated by
people rushing out of grog shops in
Boston and confronting the British
soldiers on the street those people were
almost all drunk for sure and they
cursed and they threw horse manure at
the British soldiers and they were very
a very motley rabble as John Adams
described them and you also remind
people that he was the one who defended
yeah and he took instead of the soldiers
because he knew that he was about he was
you know if we were to take control of
this this land we would need to have a
disciplined citizenry citizenry to
maintain social order so he actually
that was his the lesson he took from
that we must train these people to be
what what the Founding Fathers called
virtuous and one of the the main scolds
of your book would would be John Adams
what was his problem he pops up all over
the place he just wrote more about this
and the other founding fathers but they
were pretty much unanimous in this in in
in this idea of Republican virtue being
necessary in a democracy the logic makes
sense my argument is not actually they
were Puritans my argument is that
democracy is puritanical what are you
you mentioned some freedoms that the
founding fathers weren't fond of can you
zero and annika one of my favorite is
dancing the Puritans were the first to
attack it the 1600s they wrote a lot of
treatises against dancing oh because it
was it represented to them femininity
softness and disorder and you know it
but mostly represented sex which is
disorderly animalistic and primitive so
sex is always being attacked throughout
this and so dancing was to them and you
know also was associated with
prostitution it was associated with
general sort of public disorder and
dancing figures into a lot of I think
what a lot of people would consider
surprising the area's mainly Irish
history you right that the Irish used to
be considered fabulous dancers so I have
three chapters in my dancing section uh
one is on the Irish immigrants ones on
the Jewish immigrants and ones on
Italian immigrants all three groups when
they got here were considered to be the
best dancers in the land better than
african-americans in particularly the
Irish and the Irish co-invented tap
dance for instance and Jews were great
dancers on stage and vaudeville
blackface minstrel shows Italians were
co-creators of jazz in New Orleans
Sicilians in particular but through the
process of assimilation they were taught
it told instructed by leaders of their
communities of their of those groups to
give up all things that resembled
anything that was african-american and
of course dancing and rhythmic dancing
and jazz of course had to go a lot of
the classic Irish jigs were denounced by
Irish leaders that's so interesting too
because it was coming from their own
people it wasn't some external force
saying stop this but again it was
considered to be an American and so they
were told to and you know this was at a
time when the Irish first got here in
large numbers in the 1830s and 40s they
were also literally living with African
Americans they were living in
neighborhoods like the Five Points in
New York living with cohabitating
fornicating with having babies with
marrying african-americans and they
shared very much this urban lower-class
culture that gave rise to all kinds of
cultural freedoms that we know cherish
another area where you could sort of
play with stereotypes in the surprising
ways you talk about the The Forgotten
history of the the great Jewish athletes
Jews were considered to be the best
natural athletes in the early 20th
century for almost 50 years until World
War two basically they absolutely
dominated the sport of boxing they
totally dominated basketball and on top
of that they invented a lot of the
modern game they were the ones who made
it less structured and more free-flowing
they invented a lot of you know
inventive creative passing and moves and
were said to be you know naturally
inclined to do that kind of thing and so
it was really quite amazing to see Jews
go from that to the sort of classic
stereotypical you know nebbish figure
you say pirates our day we're often get
I'm with that handsome I'm not the
Johnny Depp actually when he was doing
the research for Jack Sparrow found a
book called sodomy and the see her
sodomy in the pirate tradition by a
historian named BR Berg and others have
done this as well they've shown that
that there's a fair amount of evidence
to show that pirates in the Golden Age
of piracy in the early 18th century
practiced sodomy regularly and it was
just a sort of common feature of life on
a pirate ship and also when they came on
shore on leave it was not called
homosexuality that's before that term
was coined and before that concept was
invented but sodomy was pretty rampant
we
think among pirates the the sort of
heroes in my book are never are they're
never organized they're never explicitly
political they're not there's no
discourse coming from them there's no
pamphlets or manifestos that I look at
they're just living for the most part
they're just doing things they're not
supposed to be doing and by doing that
they're expanding freedom